[Music]
the possession of Hannah grace has just
hit cinemas and like all good horror
movies there is some truth to the work
that inspires the events of the film
throughout this video I'll be discussing
minor events that happen in the movie so
there will of course be spoilers if you
don't want to know anything in advance
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to my
breakdown of the real-life inspiration
behind the possession of Hannah grace in
the possession of Hannah grace we follow
Megan an ex-cop who now works in a
morgue in an interview with The Daily
dead the film's writer Brian Seb and
producer Shawn Robbins stated that the
film's initial inspiration was a
newspaper article about a woman in LA
who was ordered to take part in
community service and his service was in
a morgue
this fish-out-of-water aesthetic is
immediately something that most viewers
will pick up on when watching the film
and it certainly adds to the tension
personally I believe the film has slight
tie-ins to the real-life Exorcism of
Anneliese Michelle who was also the
inspiration for the film The Exorcism of
Emily Rose in Anna Lisa's real life she
was a young girl that began experiencing
seizures at the age of 16 she was
diagnosed with psychosis caused by
temporal lobe epilepsy and then
depression in the film depression is
given as a reason why the demon was able
to take over Hannah grace so it
definitely ties into the Hannah Lee
story by the time Hannah was 20 she
often told people that she began to hear
voices her condition worsened despite
medication and she became suicidal after
taking psychiatric medication for five
years failed to improve her symptoms
Michelle and her family became convinced
that she was possessed by a demon to me
this is clear inspiration for Hannah's
father in the film who too believes that
his daughter is possessed and even goes
so far as to kill her in order to quell
any damage that she could cause and his
family similar to Hannah's appeal to the
Catholic Church for an exorcism and they
provided this over the course of the
following months and at least stopped
eating
and died due to malnutrition and
dehydration a family and the priest that
took part in the exorcism were jailed at
due to negligence and whilst there was
never any concrete proof it's clear that
many believe that Ana was indeed
possessed personally I find the
real-life events eerily similar to the
setup of Hannah Grace's possession even
down to the neglect of her parents the
producers have not admitted any tally
ins as of such but I believe the
similarities are quite striking
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this and if you think I missed any
tie-ins make sure you leave them in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and check out my
breakdown of the film itself which will
be linked at the end of this video this
is a channel for people who are heavy
into horror so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you